(lively music)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- I'm risking...
I'm risking Covid for them.
(audience laughs)
- I love you guys.
- [Both] We love you.
- Thank you.
See you in the next play on Broadway.
- [Both] Yeah.
- Okay, but not for the same price.
(both laughing)
(audience laughs)
Okay, we'll talk.
This is very nice.
Thank you so much.
This is beautiful.
I gotta tell you, this means a lot to me.
It really means a lot.
I feel so bad about the Oscar I got
for writing the original
screenplay for "The Producers".
I feel so, so bad.
I miss it, I miss it so much.
I never should have sold it.
(audience laughs)
Hey, listen, you know, times
weren't great, you know.
(audience laughs)
But as comics often say and
don't mean it, seriously...
(audience laughs)
Seriously, I gotta blow my nose seriously.
Nobody else does things that I do, right?
They're all different.
Sometimes...
Sometimes they're good,
sometimes they stink.
(nose blowing)
(audience laughs)
This is medium.
It's just medium.
(audience laughs)
What does one say?
I mean, when your peers
appreciate your work
and they salute you
with this golden statue,
it means a great deal, it really does.
Because I was the baby of four boys
and finally they got
to see me and kiss me.
And it meant a lot to be
awarded a place in the family.
And it's the same thing in show business.
If you're fellow writers,
directors, actors,
et cetera, like you and
appreciate your work,
it means a lot.
It means a whole lot.
And then, like I said, to salute you
with this wonderful statue is...
It's terrific.
I won't sell this one, I swear to God.
(audience laughs)
Okay, I've said...
I said everything I want to say
and I'm gonna listen to everybody else try
to make it after me. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Anyway, bless you.
(audience applauds)
(soaring orchestral music)